But in May of last year, Warren Buffett's Berkshire Hathaway...
...disclosed that it made a one-billion-dollar bet on Apple's stock,...
...boosting the company's market value by 18 billion dollars...
...and setting off the iPhone maker's ascent back into record territory.
Buffett's bet was followed by another rally...
...after the presidential election in November,...
...when investors speculated that companies with large overseas cash holdings...
...would benefit from the policies of the Trump administration...
...and a Republican-controlled Congress.
This latest surge to clear the 133-dollar-per-share hurdle...
...puts Apple's market value at about 130 billion dollars,...
...ahead of the number two company Alphabet...
...and beyond the values of Exxon Mobil and JP Morgan Chase combined.